I had the biggest crush in the whole
world on him the whole time
Ariana Grande says it was love at first
sight with fiance Pete Davidson the
couple first met when ariana hosted SNL
in 2016
she told Jimmy Fallon on Thursday's
Tonight Show she fell hard and fast I
left and I like jokingly said to my tour
manager I was like I'm I was like I'm
marrying him 100% like I'm like I was
like I'm literally marrying him the only
person who adores Pete as much as Ariana
her 92 year old grandma who she calls
Nonna Nonna loves him well the first
time I faced him she called him David
nice Italian boy huh I'm only 20% but I
could be more if you if you want Ari
appeared on the late-night show to
promote her new album sweetener which
features a song called you guessed it
Pete Davidson
I was made and I sent it to him and I
didn't know what to call it
so I called it he isn't gonna be that or
like this is about Pete Davidson but the
night wasn't just about sweetener ariana
performed a touching tribute to the
Queen of Soul the late Aretha Franklin
[Music]